well international travel is slowly
returning to las vegas as jeremy j ford
reports there is now a push from
homeland security to make sure the
experience for foreign visitors is safe
the airport here for international
visitors
is as safe as it's ever been benny
thompson is the chairman of homeland
security he tells me tuesday's meeting
at harry reid international was to get a
better understanding of what's needed to
increase international visitation a
majority of
international travels come through this
airport for nevada it's a significant
part of the economy congresswoman dina
titus addressed issues like mask
requirements coveted testing and
check-in procedures all of those things
are good tools in the toolbox but we
need to get the message out especially
internationally this is what you have to
do to come as it was agreed up in the
meeting california congressman lou
correa says you get your four vaccines
you're safe you get in you enjoy and you
go back home a message they want
travelers coming into nevada to be aware
of my job is to make sure that
security and protocols are in place so
that people will want to come we're
going to make sure we're safe the
economy grows tourism from other parts
of the world continues to come
and we're back on track jeremy j ford
live local now